what i want to do in this video is think
about how does the circumference and how
does the area of a circle change as we
change its radius in particular we'll
focus on what happens when we double its
radius so let's think about a circle
right over here
so this is a circle
and let's say its radius is
x units whatever our units is so this
distance right over here is x
and then let's think about another
circle that has twice the radius so its
radius will be 2x and so let me draw its
radius first so i get so it looks
roughly accurate so this is 2x is this
circle's radius and so the circle might
look something like
that that's my best attempt at freehand
drawing a circle
so let's just think about what the
circumference of both of these are and
what the areas of both of these are
so the circumference of any circle is 2
pi times the radius so in this case the
circumference and i'll use c for
circumference
is equal to 2 pi times the radius which
in this case is x
well what's the circumference here well
once again the circumference is equal to
2 pi times the radius but this time the
radius is
2x
so the circumference is equal to 2 times
pi times 2 times x which is the same
thing as 2 times 2 times pi times x or
we could write it as 4
pi
x
so we see here that this circumference
is twice as large as this one to go from
2 pi x to 4 pi x you have to multiply
multiply by 2. so you double the radius
it doubled the circumference now what
about the area and i'll do area in a new
color
so we already know that area is equal to
pi r squared in this circle the radius
is of length x so it's pi
times x squared in this circle right
over here the area is going to be equal
to pi
times the radius squared but now the
radius is 2x
to x squared now what is this going to
be equal to
well our area is equal to pi
2x squared is 2x times 2x which is the
same thing as 4x squared
4x squared or we could rewrite this as
area is equal to
pi
x squared notice now the area has
increased not by a factor of 2 the area
has increased by a factor a factor of 4
when we doubled the radius now why did
this happen i encourage you to pause the
video and think about it
well it comes straight out of the
formulas for circumference and area
remember circumference
is equal to two pi r
while area
this in a different color
area
is equal to pi
r squared
so you see here areas are proportional
to the square of the radius so if you
double this you're going to increase
your area by a factor of 4. if you
triple it if you triple your radius
you're going to increase your area by a
factor of 9. if you increase your radius
by a factor of 4 you're going to
increase your area by a factor of 4
squared or 16. while circumference
whatever factor you increase your radius
the circumference is going to increase
by that same factor and if you don't
believe me i mean we essentially showed
it right here through a little bit of
algebra but you could try it out with as
many numbers as you see fit